so we begin with breaking news and
myanmar's deposed leader Ang San tsuchi
is facing more time in prison she's been
found guilty of five counts of
corruption and is sentenced to a
combined seven years in jail the former
Nobel Peace Prize winner has now been
jailed for a total of 33 years on a
range of offenses since the military
seized power in February last year so
she denies the allegations for more on
this let's talk to tamon nabili who's
following the case from Singapore and
Tamar she has been in prison since
February and this is the last of the
cases brought against her
it is she's uh faced 19 charges in all
Nick the previous charges and sentences
and verdicts handed down a while back as
you say with a total of 26 years for
those these final five charges were
heard inside the court in neighbor door
behind closed doors on Monday the
verdicts decided then and announced to
the public just a couple of hours ago
adding another seven years on to the
total number of years that she needs to
serve which at the age of 77 basically
amounts to a life sentence for her 33
years would take her well past her 110th
birthday so it would appear under the
current circumstances that her
leadership and her participation in
Myanmar politics is all but at an end
what's the international position on
what's going on in Myanmar and the U.N
security Council applying some pressure
well the international position has
always been fairly uh unanimous Nick
they've condemned and criticized the
Myanmar position two varying degrees
because while the criticism may have
been a verbal it's not necessarily in
terms of action now the U.N action that
you mentioned occurred earlier on this
week where there was a un Council
resolution the first one on Myanmar
since it gained independence 75 years
ago condemning outright what has been
going on in Myanmar demanding uh that uh
aung San tsuchibi said free and that
action be taken towards restoring
democracy in the country the United
Nations wants everyone to return to what
was a peace plan outlined by asean a
while ago asean came through with what
was called The Five Points consensus
which me and Mark promptly ignored and
did nothing about so what the
International Community has been
demanding is that they return to the
Five Points consensus and abide by the
terms set through there but that doesn't
seem like it's going to happen anytime
soon either because asean uh excluded
Myanmar from its recent high-level
meetings and the meetings of some
foreign ministers that took place in
Thailand just a short while ago was not
attended by five fully half of the asean
foreign ministers so the amount of
consensus there is towards actually
taking any action would appear despite
this U.N resolution to be very muted and
almost inconsequential
for example we'll leave it there for now
thanks very much terminal Billy uh
reporting there from Singapore thank you